hello everyone thank you all for coming
I'm so excited to be here Budapest is a
beautiful city I'm from San Francisco my
name is Ahmad le - I'm software engineer
and web / experienced team at Pinterest
and one of the projects that I've been
working on last year is react migration
and today I'm going to tell you a story
about our journey to react we'll take a
look into challenges we faced and
techniques we used while migrating
pinterest profiles to react if you have
any questions please make a note and
i'll be happy to answer them in the end
so today's presentation is broke into
four major parts and the first one is
about how we why we decided to migrate
to react at all and not any other
library the second part is about how we
had to prepare on our infrastructure
first before we were able to build
something in reality the third part is
about measuring the impact and this
pretty important part because during
migrations like that you may introduce
bugs or break something and you'll never
know if you're not measuring the things
that you're building and the last part I
will share you the details how our life
and engineering life has changed after
adoption of react so first of all why we
had to move away from the existing
framework at all and the existing
framework Denzel which was built into
2013 served us well until a certain
period of time but nowadays it's
outdated it's very common to many other
frameworks that were introduced during
the time three four five years ago and
it's based on object-oriented JavaScript
paradigm and it uses components based
here are key so one of the most common
questions is why we decided to move to
react and not to angular ember or meteor
or anything else and on this slide you
can see a list of requirements that we
head to our new framework and we want to
have a framework with a large developer
community and react has a huge developer
community and
to take advantage of these developer
community another requirement is design
patterns and react is very compatible
with our legacy stack and it makes the
emigration to many other frameworks much
easier the third requirement is solution
for isomorphism or so-called Universal
rendering and now we'll tell you later
why this is so important for us and in
that requirement is performance and
react is well known for its performance
benefits you probably heard about
virtual Dom and reconciliation algorithm
and so and so forth and the last thing
is developer experience and this is our
old legacy stack and you might have
something similar in your project we
have Python junga web server ginger
renderer on the back end nine checks on
the client and it's old as well but
being on board with all of these like
mojo bundler Redux
just unit tests and many other tools and
features has completely changed the way
we develop our modern web apps so just
to give you an idea of scale that we
operated we have 200 200 millions of
monthly active users which is more than
population of the biggest country in the
world Russia we serve more than 150,000
requests per second and since we
constantly ship new features we run
hundreds of experiments we can't just
simply freeze our product development in
order to rebuild the new web app from
scratch and react and while it's
relatively easy to build a new web app
in react changing a service immigrating
service that is constantly changing is
like changing engines of an airplane
while mid-flight
so how how many of you have tried to
rewrite your web app from from scratch
in any other framework again we see a
lot of hands and I try to do this before
and ended up in situation when I had old
web app which is still in production
and many almost hundreds of engineers
were completely changing it adding new
features and had me new one which is
still under development and I had to
port all these features back to the to
the new one and it's like the constant
race condition not the best situation to
be in
so now how can we avoid this and the
only way to avoid this is to rewrite our
web app part by part while there the
rest is still run by the old framework
and now we're coming to this idea of
so-called hybrid app it's an app where
we have two frameworks and they plug
this together together for the time of
the migration and thus our engineers
will not have to write everything at
once they will be able to migrate it
piece by piece so now we want to ask
question how can we make a hybrid app
and the very first thought maybe it's
not that complicated but let's take a
look at the list of the all possible
challenges and the very first challenge
is that react is obviously JavaScript
framework and how many of you have
JavaScript on the server side I can see
a little bit of hands but obviously not
everyone and having JavaScript on the
server side is not a very common thing
but having javascript in Python PHP or
Java or many other server-side languages
is very rare it's obviously not a common
at all so in order to enable our
JavaScript rendering on the server side
we had to prepare infrastructure first
and some of you may ask the question why
do I actually need so-called Universal
or isomorphic rendering and there is two
reasons for that
first of all our engineers they will not
have to write their templates twice so
we're saving their work in time and the
other reason is yes here
and even though nowadays search engines
they can execute JavaScript and parse
page that is rendered on the client-side
we run a bunch of experiments it's still
better to serve the initial markup as a
string as an HTML string so the second
challenge is rendering react components
inside of the old
and while react is pretty flexible in
terms of rendering as long as you can
provide it a container Dom element there
still might be some challenges and for
example what if your template files are
stored your what if your templates are
started in separate files or what if
your templates using a custom made
template language and such example is
ginger templates in Python and non Dex
in JavaScript so the third challenge is
dealing with the old resources and more
likely in your your your project you
have a resource layer which does all the
communication with the API and probably
you want to reuse it at least for the
first period of time unless you want to
really rebuild everything from scratch
in react and you have to Web Apps as we
discussed before so dealing with the old
resources is another challenge and the
last challenge is how can we make sure
that newly created UI and components
they're actually performing better than
the old ones what if we introduced a bar
for performance issues and something is
going wrong with the users so here we
outline our four main challenges and now
let's dive deeper into each of those and
before let me give you a high-level
overview of our web app architecture as
you can see on this slide there is
nothing crazy we have a client-side web
app Python junga web server and we have
pack an API and when a user agent sends
a request to the to the server the
server renders HTML with ginger render
in Python and sends back all this HTML
to the client which spawns a bunch of
requests for CSS images in JavaScript
and many other assets it initializes the
app and after that our subsequent
requests are handled only only for
retrieving the additional data so there
is no more subsequent renders on the on
the server side all the renders are
happening on the client side and because
of that we had so-called isomorphic
rendering so now let me give you a
little bit
contacts about ginger rendering engine
and Python and nunchucks in JavaScript
and these templating languages are very
similar almost identical and because of
that we had so-called isomorphic
rendering and the only one caveat in
this approach was that we had to have
two sets of utils you can see there is
one set youtubes in libraries for python
and another one for nunchucks in
javascript not the best approach because
you have to run tests and do all these
things that are not the best how many of
you are familiar with nunchucks or
ginger at all not that many people but
that's fine because I'm gonna go into a
high-level overview of this templating
language and it's pretty common similar
to many other languages on this slide
you can see small code snippet we are
initializing three variables very common
to many template templating languages on
this line you can see that we are
executing our template and if creating a
name is empty the render hello guest
welcome to Pinterest and finally on this
slide we are rendering a module called
home feed and module is a function call
in Java C it will be converted to
function call in JavaScript which will
file home feed module and it will render
for us passing all the options as a
properties does it look familiar for you
know any react people so it seems like
this architecture fits very well into
each other this is a react code snippet
and we reading properties with calling
home feed module we passing all the
options of the properties as well and
home field is not is another function
call in react so this looks very it
seems like these architectures fits very
well into each other
but the only one issue is that
JavaScript and Python is not commenting
at all or any other server-side language
because of that is a very first step we
enabled non Jax rendering on a
standalone node.js server that enables
JavaScript rendering on the on the
server side this will unblock nunchuks
rendering and our engineers would have
to rebuild the whole thing at once
but they will be able to migrate
incrementally rewriting our web app
piece by piece as a bonus we can reuse
the same youtubes and libraries so there
is no more duplicating libraries only in
JavaScript no more in Python so now we
have a plan for our migration at first
will migrate from Gingin Python and X on
the client tune and X on the on the
server and on the client and now let's
take a look how our rendering used to
work before we introduced node.js
sidebar as I mentioned before our
templates are structured as a trees a
root module can have children module and
children modules can have more children
modules and a renderer pass traverses
the tree rendering each of these node
and combining them into resulting HTML
so a user agent sends a request to the
to the Python jungle web server then we
send a request to the backend API in
order to retrieve the initial data for
the template and we start rendering our
templating tree so we render it as far
as we can go until additional data is
needed at this point worst to mention
that this process is CPU blocking so
nothing else can be rendered in this
process and this happens serially at
this point we'll request additional data
from the back in API and we continue our
rendering as far as we can go until
additional data needed and we're
requesting additional data and in the
end after the whole template is rendered
with sending the resulting HTML now
let's take a look what happened after we
introduced a node.js sidecar as you can
see the Harket texture is
similar to what we had before but now we
have injects proxy layer for load
balancing and we have a set of node.js
workers as it was before we're sending a
request from the user agent and we're
requesting the additional data from the
API after that we're sending a request
over network to our node.js server in
order to render our nunchuks template so
here where it becomes different we're
starting rendering with node.js server
over network and that's we were able to
enable JavaScript rendering on the
server side is it first before it
renders the template as far as it is it
can go until additional data is needed
and at this point it returns back
partially rendered template as a
response and our Python Django web
server requests more data from the
backend API so now we repeat the process
but the only difference is now we can
send multiple requests one for each sub
tree in order to paralyze rendering
process and we rendered it as far as we
can go again and this process is not CPU
blocking anymore so after a both sub
trees are rendered in parallel we send
back independent responses to the to the
passenger junga web server and we
continue process again and again
requesting additional data if it's
needed we send multiple requests and we
continue rendering until the tree is
fully rendered and at this point we send
the resulting HTML to the user agent so
if you can see the approach is very
similar to what we had before but now
we're rendering JavaScript templates on
a standalone node.js servers server and
you can use this approach in many
different languages we use it in iPhone
but if you are in Java or PHP or you
something else even like cold fusion
someone is using it still then you can
use the same approach so now at this
point we were able to solve our first
challenge and we can render nunchucks
templates on the client and on the
server and now we can go ahead and solve
our second challenge let me provide a
little bit of context about the old
framework Denzel Denzel is very very
similar to many other frameworks that
were introduced three four or five years
ago its component based framework and
uses object-oriented inheritance
approach and on this slide you can see
two nunchuks statements and one of them
is old denzel module code and another
one is new react component code and as I
mentioned before module is a function
call it basically converts to JavaScript
call which will render for us Oh Denzel
component since it the same applies to
the component called component calls
another function call but it falls back
to react rendering so in order to
empower our engineers to migrate our
service incrementally with tweak than
Jax code and we introduced a new keyword
component which represents the bridge
between Denzel and react
so once nunchuks rendering its component
keyword it will render it Denzel react
bridge instead and on the slide you can
see a simplified version of Denzel reg
bridge which is a Denzel module which
will render for us react component let's
take a look how it works
so once the component is added to the
Dom it will read its own options and it
will figure out the name of the react
component that they want to render and
it will render this component passing
all the options to the properties
the rendering will happen in its own
container Dom element so this is pretty
simple but pretty powerful technique and
you can use it in many other JavaScript
libraries if you want to migrate from
one library to react and you want to use
the same libraries together during
period of migration some of you may ask
a really good question how react will
reuse the services rendered markup on
the client-side and this is a really
cool feature of react because once the
HTML is rendered on the server-side
react to automatically add a checksum to
it and after the web app is initialized
react to render the HTML in its own
virtual Dom not a real dumb but virtual
Dom and will generate another checksum
and if this checks I'm sorry the same
that means that we can reuse the
existing HTML and will not have to
change the Dom elements at all this is
pretty important for many performance
optimizations and also it reduces UI
flickering that you might see when Dom
has changed after javascript is
initialized think it's one of the really
cool features of react so now since we
can render react components inside of
the old framework we can deal with the
old resource later and more likely in
your project you have ajax library or
library that is building on top of ajax
request that does all the communication
to the api for you and certain serves
all the data from the server to to the
client and probably at least for the
first period of time of migration you
really want to reuse this library and
for that purpose we use powder
components as adaptors if you don't know
how the component is a very powerful
technique that helps you to reuse
components logic while remaining
components composable it's a function
that takes a component and returns
another component I know it may sound a
little bit confusing but let's take a
look to the example and I think
everything will be clear
so on this slide you can see on the left
side it's a hoc with the resource that
helps us to communicate with the API and
with the older resource layer and on the
right side you can see the example of
usage of hoc with resource so what
happens on component it mount when the
component is already in the Dom it will
send a request to the resource layer and
once the data comes back it will change
its own state thus it will render its
own components and no trigger rendering
of the of the child this is pretty
simple but pretty powerful technique
that helps a lot in migrations like that
and you can use it for many other things
not only for dealing with resources but
this one is the main one for example if
you have some experiments layer or
something else you can always make sure
that the newly created reaction ponents
and architecture are always in sync with
the with the with this layer so now we
can render nunchuks on the server we can
render react on the server on the client
and now we can move forward and solve
our last and fourth challenge so now
we're talking about UI experiments and
this is the most exciting part for me
with more than 200 200 millions of
monthly active users we have to roll out
things very carefully because we have to
make sure that our newly created UI is
actually performing better than the old
one and for that purpose we use
gatekeeper a be testing framework and if
you have something similar in your
project it's super handy normally maybe
testing frameworks are used to compare
different UIs and see how they behave
and measure
the data and impact but you can use
these frameworks as well for for
migrations or factoring like that so on
this slide you can see there is a very
simplified version of forking logic
based off on experiment check and if
user is in the react experiment then we
render newly created react component and
otherwise we'll fall back to the old
Denzel module now let's take a look
deeper at the experiment setup you can
see component tree or module tree on the
right side and this component tree at
some node something zell node you can
see that we are forking our experiment
logic and the whole right subtree is
still rendered in in denzel but the left
one is in react so worse to mention that
once a node is converted to component
call old children and descendants are
necessarily in reality basically there
is call of react inside of Denzel but
there is no call of the ins on one side
of react and this is done on purpose
because it helps you to move faster and
also it will be total mess if you start
calling react inside of themselves and
then downside of react and vice-versa
you don't want to you really don't want
to do this because of that we had to
convert our components from the very
leaves moving to the very top and we
call it bottom-up approach also it's
worse to mention that you probably want
to run your experiments at maximum per
page level and you don't want to compare
your old web up to the new one otherwise
you have too many factors affecting your
data and you'll never be able to figure
out why you have metrics drops or why I
have maybe metric improvements also it's
forced to mention that you really want
to run your experiments exclusively and
otherwise you'll have the same issue
because different experiments will
affect the same metrics
later on you can login into your
experiments dashboard and see different
metrics so while we were running
immigration like that we were comparing
reacting Denzel to many different
metrics like engagement metrics or error
rate performance metrics and so on and
so forth on this slide you can see a
screenshot of the dashboard and you can
see there is a bunch of metrics on the
left side and there is a bunch of
squares on the right side the ones that
without color they actually gray and
means that there is no not enough data
to calculate the numbers so they will be
statistically significant
the red ones means there is a drop and
the blue ones means there is improvement
if there is a job you probably really
want to investigate it and figure out
maybe you introduced a bug or maybe
there is a performance issues that
affecting your user it's important to
say that during migrations like that you
may have a bunch of outta task unit
tests manual testing and things like
that but unlikely they will cover all
the edge cases for example what if your
well what if in your web app there is
something going on wrong in in different
language or what if people with poor
internet connection they having some
issues and it's really hard to catch
things like that using unit tests or out
a test or anything else but maybe
testing frameworks and measuring that
your data will always give you a signal
that something is going wrong and you
can start investigating so interest
profiles were the first user heavy page
that was successful immigrated to
reality and during react migration we've
seen consistent performance and
engagement improvements for example
metrics like Dom interactive or board
page views were up to 20% and we got
this 20% just from changing the gears
and infrastructure without actually
changing UI adult I think this is pretty
cool getting 20% from without changing
the
during migration our engineers our
product engineers they were able to
continue changing the service and they
were able to ship different features and
run different experiments in the rest of
the website and finally all these leads
to completely new developer experience
now we don't have duplicating nunchucks
and ginger libraries there is no need to
learn nunchucks at all that makes the
onboarding process much easier there is
single language on the client and on the
server side which makes life of our
engineers even more easier and finally
we are part of the large developer
community and there is no need in wiki
pages there is a lot of well-crafted
examples and documentation online it's
been a long journey but we're excited to
be part of react community thank you and
if you have any questions feel free to
find me in
you